[Music]
Steve we're all so happy for you you're
such a talented nice person you've had
so much success but I think it's good to
explore with with people that have done
so well and let young people know that
what didn't always go this well for you
you struggled a little bit you had some
get some crappy jobs I did up again
happy jobs yeah one of my first jobs who
I worked in the produce department of a
supermarket and I would one of my jobs
to wrap fruit in plastic wrap and and I
was bad I was pretty much I was bad at
at every aspect of the job it was it
doesn't seem I mean I'm not even trying
mean solely but doesn't sound like it'd
be that hard what was the what was the
problem
well you there was a hot plate and it
would it would melt the underneath the
wrap it would melt the plastic but I
would put my hands on it and melt my
hands like I'd burned my hands and I had
to also stock stock the shelves and we
and in the produce section we stocked
popcorn among other things and if I one
day I poked a hole and in the bag of
popcorn and the popcorn spilling out and
I became Jerry Lewis so there's the
popcorn how do I stop a 900 pound bag of
poop yeah
to me it seemed that way so I took one
of those at that point you had the guns
that they put the you know the price tag
on it and the stickers so I I fixed it
with about 18 little price tags and then
my manager came by about an hour later
to check my work
oh what's this and he pulled the sticker
away and popcorn
Jerry Lewis oh wow Jerry you uh you were
you a telemarketer for a while I sold I
sold wine by phone how do you sell wine
over the phone eggs you can't do it and
you had all of you know you have your
cards the varietal characteristics of
this you say things like oaky a lot but
when it's buttery
exactly when in doubt say well it has it
it has a buttery sort of afterbirth what
what did you say you're a terrible
jumper one day of my life you know
people say this about you all the time
you get this and I think it's a
double-edged sword or I'm guessing it is
that Steve probably such a nice guy such
a nice guy such a normal nice guy and
those are a lot of the characters that
you play and I would think at some point
does that ever get do you ever fantasize
about they're people like a Sean Penn or
a Jack Nicholson who are known for being
abrasive and so I've actually seen those
guys be kind of brusque with people and
people love it if they can tell us
someone to eff off and the person's like
wow wow I got he really zinged me he
really got me and they love it but you
you always have to be nice it's
interesting because I just did a bunch
of press for this movie with Meryl
Streep and Tommy Lee Jones and Tommy Lee
Jones is a guy who does not suffer fools
he is yeah you know he's a pretty tough
guy and to watch him with the press is
amazing because they're like mr. Joe
they're so afraid of him right and he's
got them right where he wants them well
me on the other hand if they don't
there's no respect
that is not true there's a ton of
respect but it's just that thing worth
if you ever cracked for a minute and got
slightly irritated with someone else
correctly that's the thing I don't
really think I'm that nice I think I'm
probably just a sociopath who
understands that niceness sells you're
saying there's no one behind that mass
who knows
[Laughter]